I think most guys just like boobs they
can be big they can be small they can be
fake they can be real they're good all
around if you're not happy with your
breasts and you need to make them bigger
to like feel more confident then I mean
so be it
it's gonna be like really hard mochi I
think we're feeling something that let
go then someone which is kind of weird
[Music]
oh they're like liquid that is not what
I pictured at all
that's I mean it's like a waterbed I
can't get over that noise yeah that
noise is such a fat off
yeah you can't sound like a dishwasher
when you're having sex to me this feels
significantly heavier than a regular
breast but I'm also not normally judging
the weight of regular breasts a little
bit like hardened mochi filled with
water it kind of looks like a like a
jellyfish if I close my eyes that does
sort of feel like fat it doesn't feel
like a water balloon it feels just like
pure tissue this one feels nice yeah
this feels a lot like a butt yeah I it
passes the Nestle test
this is a balloon four days after the
birthday party it's like the t1000 in
Terminator when he's like liquid metal
it's not as perky as the other one it's
like a pancake I feel your head that's
truly good this thing's got a stretch
this is a big addition to your chest
this is gonna be a really good mousepad
like a rest like a prince good I want to
have a water balloon fight with me it's
just like it seems like the morality of
breast implant surgery is something that
like women need to decide amongst
themselves if you want to do something
like that just make sure you research
everything about it like to make sure
that you're gonna be comfortable with
what's gonna happen because that's
something that you're gonna have to live
with for like the rest of your life it's
not about how the world perceives you
it's about how you perceive yourself
there are ways to feel better about
yourself that don't involve surgery
chaucer shouldn't feel pressured to have
a certain size boob because all boobs
are beautiful if they got like stranded
in a desert or something and they needed
like a little water supply of just any
injury